hello everyone my name is jonita
manolova and together with my colleague
dominicani from glass and our partners
Camille condors and Yandex from and
effect we'll share in today's session
our experiences of building an
interactive dashboard to monitor the
data quality
but before we move to the Deep technical
part
I would like to describe the problem we
had and draw the bigger picture in order
to fully understand some of the
decisions we made
foreign data
I'm just not sure I'll just make a short
break I'm not sure whether the slides
are shown because I don't see this on my
screen
perfect
thank you very much
so
for for this um
let's start first with who is the global
legal entity identifier Foundation or
short click live
we are not-for-profit Swiss Foundation
founded by the stability the financial
stability board Clive activities are
overseen by the regulatory oversight
committee or for short Rock which is
made up of more than 65 representatives
of public authorities from around the
globe
life is managing a network of Partners
mainly the Lei issuing organizations and
our task is to ensure the operational
stability of the global Lei system and
to promote the lei
currently there are more than 2.2
million leis issued in the system
but what is an Ali you will ask
Lei stands for legal entity identifier
it is an ISO standard a 20 digit
alphanumeric code and connects to legal
entities reference data such as the name
the little form the address of an entity
and where it is registered
furthermore it provides information
about corporate actions children or
parent entities as well as some fund
specific relationship types
so so far this doesn't sound too
complicated right
the data seems to be quite well
described and clear so what can go wrong
here
there's just this one specialty as
mentioned we are managing a network of
Partners who are distributed all around
the world all following their local
standards
they provide us with their entire data
pool on a daily basis take the data
from the different sources and make it
available in a Consolidated form free of
charge is a public good on our website
in order to improve the transparency in
the financial sector
but at the same time we are not allowed
to touch manipulate edit or clean the
data
and we are responsible for the data
quality management
and yes I did mention public good data
is a probably good the Lei data
um with all connected reference data of
legal entities information as you just
saw it on the screen is
available
um
as an open source data free of charge on
live.org you don't even need to register
or create an account you can just go
there and simply search the entire
repository via the Lei search we make
available download download the the
files which are by the way updated three
times a day or simply use the glyph API
to explore the information about
more than 2.2 million entities and their
historic
updates
as you can see
[Music]
um
the data is highly standardized
following different either standards and
using XML schema definition to secure
the file formats
in addition we have defined the whole
data quality management framework to
maintain the quality at the required
level
for this we have defined different
quality criteria maturity levels data
quality checks and what you see on the
screen we call
um data quality Gates we publish monthly
reports on the entire data pool as well
as on the individual lei issuer
and still
we were missing some bits and pieces
some events happening in between reports
and we were surprised at the end of the
month when we generated the reports
we were basically sitting on all this
data but we were not fully utilizing it
there came the idea to create an
interactive dashboard for monitoring the
data quality and the activities of the
individual Lei issuers enabling
ourselves to react timely to outlier and
single events and thus to prevent this
becoming repetitive and systematic
issues creating unwanted patterns in the
data
one of the main criteria
for choosing the tool and platform for
creating this dashboard was to be
flexible so we can adjust and modify as
we see fit in an uncomplicated workflow
and also here we are following the
guiding principle for everything we do
of being transparent so the dashboard we
have created is now publicly available
and you can check it out on the DQ minus
dashboard.live.org
but now back to the topic of this
session how did we get there
so if you want to start a web project as
a python developer using open source
Technologies you might find yourself in
front of a jungle of cool Technologies
and Frameworks that you could use for
your project and just might not be sure
which one would be the best for your use
case
so in this presentation today we will
take you on our decision journey and
give you some insights into what we
learned on the way and what helped us
decide which technology to use
so the first thing you need to build a
web project using python as a web
framework this framework will allow you
to connect your backend database with
your front-end application using apis
and there are many cool open source web
Frameworks available and here in this
next slide you can see three example
projects Django flask and fast API
in the table we pasted some basic
indicators that can help you decide if
an open source framework is a good fit
to build a stable project
for example you could look at the time
of the release and this will give you
the maturity of the prog project
you could also look at the stars and the
contributors of a project which will
give you a feeling for the activity and
the community behind the project
and taking these numbers into account
you're pretty much good to go with any
of the Technologies shown in the slide
it really just depends on your needs the
scale of your project and the prior
knowledge that you have in any of the
existing python Frameworks
so in our case we decided to go for fast
API
while building the dashboard we want it
to be flexible and able to experiment on
some of the features
in order to do this we had monthly
meetings with live where they would give
us feedback and it was crucial for us to
be able to react to this feedback
quickly and we found that fast API
really supported us in this and allowed
rapid prototyping this was mainly
because the documentation of the tool
was really good and allowed developers
new to the tool to learn it quickly and
get up to speed and because of this we
decided to stay with fast API after we
had tested it for the project initially
so fast API is built on the Starlet
framework and it also supports a
synchronous code out of the box using a
sync and a weight python keywords and
this is what makes it so fast
fast API is also built on the pedantic
type pins to validate serialize and
deserialize data so what does this mean
as you can see in the code example we
created
we created a typecat cat has a name cat
has some attributes such as age or
furiness to describe it
and in the bottom we have an example API
call that would post the cat object to
our application if it has the correct
type
so if a user for example would create a
cat object with I don't know the age
furriness this wouldn't make sense
because H can be for it has to be an
integer and this would fail and it
wouldn't be pasted into our application
and this way we can ensure that only the
correct values are shared throughout our
application
and using this fast API can then also
Auto generate open API documents which
is really cool and saves a lot of time
as we would otherwise have to do all of
this work manually
so the last two lessons that we learned
using fast API were that it was
extremely helpful to use fast api's
dependency injection system for
repetitive tests such as yielding a
database or formatting pagination
parameters
and what we also found that it is best
to do any kind of data validation in the
endpoints itself it's totally not
necessary to use pandas or any kind of
other Frameworks for this because fast
API really supports us out of the box
and you can just save a lot of code
yeah so this is what we learned from
Fast API
so different data sources are the core
of our application in the dashboard we
connect different kind of data sources
so we have rest apis we have relational
databases the question is how we connect
to these different data today we will
introduce the learnings around
relational databases that we've made
however some of the findings are also
easily transferable to other data
sources
so let us begin with how we can connect
Python and relational databases so we
use to object relational mapping library
in this case SQL Alchemy to uh connect
python to Marina debate relational
object relational mapping is also called
orm of course you can also just use
database apis without an orm but over
orms make it easy to switch between
dialects and to switch our databases
but also orms allows us to map
single database roles either from tables
or database views to python objects
similar approaches are also available
for noise scaled databases like mongodb
we can write queries without writing a
single line of SQL although previous
knowledge of SQL helps us to write these
queries and also improve the query
performance SQL queries can be written
in a pythonic way so that it can be read
by other developers that do not have
knowledge of SQL so that they can be
easily onboarded
also the orm helps us to express complex
database relations and to easily query
them so the who I am in general reduces
the complexity but not all only
inquiring data but also in the way of
how to connect the databases and to
simplify transactions with the database
so in the code example you can see a
small example how we query uh
the
database table
checks and how we link the check text
to this
to this database without defining a join
this all automatically happens in the
back and then this is automatically
translated into
um
python objects
so how can you decide which Library you
want to choose so you're probably
familiar with all the different
database libraries or amps that are
available
in Python so we have SQL Alchemy which
is a very mature
project we have tortoise which tries to
translate the Django or m-like style
into an async framework we have paniora
M which allows you to write SQL in a
more pythonic way and here
as previously said you should go with
the framework that you're most familiar
with and that fits your use case if you
are already using Django you probably
want to stick with the Django RM
and don't want to change this uh you can
also additionally see here how many
questions have been asked on stack
Overflow
um the results for Django or M
um are not displayed in for PV but for
the libraries and as you can see for SQL
like me you'll find a lot of questions
and answers on
um stack Overflow in the beginning we
decided to go with orata or M but this
is not supported anymore and therefore
it decided to switch to SQL Alchemy and
to replace some of our older code and
rewrite that code using SQL Alchemy
coming to the learnings so something
that we noticed from the very much
beginning is that migrations are very
powerful tool that ensure the continuity
of your service so when you want to
change anything in your database
structure you probably want to use
migrations to do that to ensure that
your service is still running after you
change anything in the database
something that we've also noticed is
that it's really helpful to aggregate as
much of the data in the beginning and
use material materialized views that are
updated by triggers for example at night
um aggregating the data in the beginning
um increases the query speed and hence
increases the speed of your dashboard
then we also noticed that it's really
clever to check whether a framework is
still supported before you start coding
your API in our case we noticed quite
late that or rata or M is not
support it anymore and that we had to
switch to SQL Alchemy
um that also uh applies to another
learning that we had so you should pay
attention When selecting your framework
but there are all the statements and
operations that you are planning to use
are supported by the library that you're
choosing in our case we had to write a
lot of raw SQL in the beginning because
of what Orion was not supporting some
more complex SQL
um
uh statements
so and then last but not least we
noticed that the performance mostly
depends on the database setup and the
queries that you write of course and you
should start optimizing once you are
able to measure performance so when you
have a query you can Benchmark that
query it makes sense start adding
indices and setting improvements but
thinking about the query performance in
the beginning is in most cases not
possible and not very helpful
foreign
coming to the next point is processing
data so as we already said uh we had a
lot of different data sources and we
said we want to aggregate that data in
early stage but how do you do that in
our case we use task queues to execute
computational heavy tasks
overnight so we have some complex
business business logic such as the data
quality score that you also find on the
start page of the dashboard that
Aggregates different data sources and
then calculates one single score
therefore we need as I said to combine
different data sources different
database tables and collect all this
data and then calculate the score what
happens is that we queue this as jobs in
the night and this is running in the
background using multiple workers so
that it can be paralyzed
so you might ask now why not just use
Chrome for that and have your python
script and just execute it with Cron
and after some researching we noticed
that Quran in Docker is a challenge and
it's not the most easy thing to do so we
decided to use the task queue and to use
salary
for task use you also have different
options
we decided to go with salary
because the ecosystem is quite strong I
come to that later
but if you're looking for some something
smaller some something simpler there's
also the redis queue there's you and
here again use the framework that you
are familiar with and also probably
speak to other developers ask them what
they have used what they have my
experiences with with and what they
would
um
suggest you
um you can also look into Solutions
outside of python for example Kafka or
Amazon Q Services which provide apis for
python
so why have we chosen salary salary
provides a really strong ecosystem so we
have the salary worker that can be
started in a Docker container we can
start multiple instances of that and
then execute tasks in these different
workers on the right side you'll see a
small program that wraps the data
quality score calculations into a task
and then in line 13 you can see how you
can then asynchronously start this task
and let this task run without inter
without any interruption in the main
program
uh you also find salary beat that we've
also started in a second uh Docker
container then which allows you to
schedule tasks
um hourly or you can run that
specifically at night in our case we use
that to start our calculations if we
know that all data has been transferred
to our data sources and last but not
least we have flower or flower which is
a monetary monitoring tool which is
built on top of salary which allows you
in a graphical interface to see how many
tasks you have queued how many tasks
have been started have many tasks have
been closed successfully and how many
tasks might fail so what are the
learnings of working with salary or
working with task use because I think
most of these learnings can be
generalized to other to other task
queues as well
though what we have noticed in the very
beginning is that it's nice to have nice
small jobs that always hear the same
result that are deterministic you should
also anticipate from the very much
beginning that your jobs will fail and
they're probably not fair because they
are written in a wrong way or you have
made a mistake but you have dependencies
you have other data sources you might
have network errors and therefore always
make sure that when you write a job that
when you restart the job that it yields
the same result and does not affect any
other results
then also there is exception handling so
salary is very powerful in exception
handling you can catch a lot of
different
exceptions you can handle errors
differently and if you want to get
deeper into that I recommend the salary
task replay guide by Innes Parker which
provides a deep Insight on on how to set
up a perception handling with salary
um something that we also learned is
it's very nice to have different cues
probably one cue for tasks that are very
slow or take longer and some for more
Speedy tasks because then you don't
block your cues and you make sure that
all your tasks uh get processed in a
timely manner finally we decided to use
redis with celery when we started this
project we worked with Revit mq but we
noticed that redis can also be useful in
other parts of application of our
application and therefore we switch to
routers
so let's talk about monitoring
our learnings regarding monitoring can
be summarized with for more of the
merrier and we earlier are better
uh simply because if you already have a
monitoring system in place in the early
stages of your project it already helps
you with debugging
in our case in the beginning we only
used Sentry and then later on we added
also Prometheus Loki and grafana
uh we are aware that depending on your
setup Century could cost some money
however we learned that it is worth it
because essentially you can basically
introduce a monitoring system with a
single line of code
now let's come to our last slide
um what are the overall learnings of
this project so over the last three
years we have collaborated with and
effect to create this data quality
dashboard that you can see on the right
hand side
and especially in the beginning of a
project we had many design iterations so
we we had many different prototypes and
the reason for that is we asked live we
were just sitting on this bunch of data
and we just wanted to go away from
having CSV files and from only having
monthly snapshots
instead we wanted to have something
where the users can actually interact
with our data and where we can get a
daily update on what has actually
happened
and it was very hard to imagine what is
actually possible in terms of dashboards
so only if you actually see the first
draft if you can play around with it
only then you get more ideas therefore
you should always acknowledge that there
could be some back and forth during the
development process
then the second thing we learned in this
project is that it makes sense to
involve all stakeholders as early as
possible
so as the needs I mentioned in the
beginning our data is actually managed
by 39 local units that are distributed
all around the world
these local units are actually managing
the Lei data and they are also
responsible for fixing any data quality
issues that means these units are
currently using this dashboard on a
daily basis in their daily operations to
identify our data quality problems and
to understand them
um other stakeholders are basically you
the public so you can actually go on
this website on this dashboard and you
can look at our data and you can verify
if there are any potential issues with
it and from an internal point of view of
the stakeholders are also our it admins
um who well they need to be involved as
soon as for instance you want to make
this dashboard public because it makes a
huge difference if you only have a small
number of users or if you open the
floodgates so to say
and for last learning office project is
having regular release Cycles
um
having a regular release cycle is quite
convenient because you always have
resources allocated you have a process
in place
and in our case we will release an
update once a month
and in some cases which could be
something small like relabeling
something fixing small bugs and in some
cases we are actually extending our Lei
data or our data quality framework so
maybe we want to add some bigger
features some new visualizations and
it's just quite convenient knowing that
there's already something some resources
allocated and there's a process already
there to do this
and of course it's a very nice excuse to
talk to our friends from end effect
and yeah that's it from our side
um please let us know if you have any
questions for us or if you would like to
share any feedback with us
looks like we've got a couple of
questions down there
have you seen this one uh
uh thank you flow OS thank you so much I
built a built a containered chrome SQL
job last week and I'm looking for an
alternative that uh something you have
an opinion on
yeah so I think um any of the task keys
that we presented are probably uh
feasible of doing that
um the question is if you want it
scheduled or if you want to trigger it
from another application
um if you want to uh trigger it by time
I think if you want to have a really
simple setup you can just look at
rediscue set up a redis container and
then have red SQ running and you can
schedule it I think with the with the
decorator so it's quite easy to set up
up
all right thank you and from Parker Kane
apologies if this was said already what
did they use for a front end for this
dashboard
come here do you want to take this I
think you've worked on this
yeah so we had a view front end with UJS
and we used beautify to build the
components with you